they seem to share prices of actually
both of your company's declined on this
new so investors didn't seem to be
buying this merger how do you convince
them that that that emerged between
Edmond human and makes sense for them
well I don't think it's all investors
Betty I actually think it's the arbs
that got in the deal looking for
opportunity and I'm not quite sure they
know how to do this trait because this
is a longer-term strategy this is a very
big combination that's going to have a
longer term impact on the quality of
health care the cost of health care in
an evolving consumer marketplace so i'm
not going sure they know how to play it
it'll settle down and the noise will
come out of the system and will do just
fine ok Bruce is it going to lower
health care costs for consumers very
much so I think as you see the
transition from a more employer-based to
a consumer based model and a value-based
reimbursement model from a
fee-for-service model these combined
organizations will have the capability
to meet both of those trends both in the
way of our clinical capabilities on a
man aside and the deep deep employer
relationships that Edna has on the on
their side mark is they're going to have
to be though some divestiture of your
business or humanness business in order
to pass regulators yes we did actually a
very detailed review body of the
businesses at a local market level so
this is not statewide this is not City
why this is down to the zip code and
rating area kind of analysis and we will
have to do some divestitures we included
those divestitures in the value of the
deal and the costs of the deal and we
still believe they get very healthy
returns over time how much I mean what
kind of chunk of revenue are we talking
about that you might have together yeah
we're we're really not broadcasting that
number that's subject to a conversation
with the Department of Justice we don't
want to get ahead of ourselves okay
because there are some estimates already
out there right you know Sterne Agee
came out and said that you might have to
give up about thirteen percent of your
revenue
in order to get this past regulators I
mean is that way off the mark I would
just say that we're not we're not going
to talk about that at this time and
everybody's doing in that analysis at a
far far less detailed level than we have
and and I think that's where the rubber
is really going to throw out in terms of
you know the value for investors you
know I understand that that that we
can't say a blanket all shareholders are
not happy or you know are not satisfied
perhaps with the deal if you look at the
share price but you know Bruce you have
to look at where you know the offer is
around 2 23 for the company the share
price though is about is well below well
below that price about thirty dollars
below that what do you think that's
telling telling you well I think it's
just telling you the where Mark was just
talking about and that's the ARBs I
think the ARBs are very confused they've
been hurt over the last few deals with a
long justice cycle and I just see that
in the stock i will tell you the
investors that we've talked to they are
very very excited about the future that
combined companies and will be holders
post deal so i don't think it's the
longer term investors i really think
there's some confusion out there on the
art side of how to play this particular
transaction considering that the FTC
review is that partly you know on you
and so in terms of the messaging to the
investors I think the messaging is gonna
have to clean not all of us are the same
buddy so I think we're going to have to
let the kind of shareholders who value
this deal find their way through it
could be a huge buying opportunity for
them for all intents and purposes and so
I think we just need to let it clear
through we've got a long train between
now and when the transaction closes
that's the point at which all of this
will be up true value and so we but
we're going to we're going to we're
going to let the market sort itself out
at mark why are these deals happening
right now I mean it seems like you've
had certainly we've seen lots of drug
deals but now we're seeing some health
insurance deals you've got anthem and
Cigna that are a play I mean why now
well I think the big story in all of
this is that the business model has to
change
we now have doctors on a cash basis
hospitals on a revenue basis and
insurers on a margin basis it's a wonder
the system works at all with three
different economic models to get
everybody on the same page we have to
have a fundamentally different level of
partnership it can no longer be
smashmouth at the local market it
actually has to be a partnership between
payers and providers on making sure that
we're getting the right outcome which is
a healthy economically productive and
happy member and so we look at that as
the outcome and we will ward the health
system for doing that we're going to
start to see trend vendors actually make
the market more affordable for consumers
Bruce do you think does any of this
though the timing at least have
something to do with what we heard from
the Supreme Court and the affirmation of
the Affordable Care Act no I I truly
believe this is a long-term trend i
think the exchanges have brought some
motivation to it but i will tell you the
ACA and and all the items related to
that stimulated these kind of
discussions but wasn't the reason I
where Mark is going this transition from
a very deep consumer centric model and a
model with value-based reimbursement is
really driving the industry from a sick
care model to a health model and there's
technology that needs to be invested in
there's partnerships that have to be
created in size and scale from the
ability to ensure its affordable offers
all of that at mark before we go I mean
speaking about the timing it did any the
fact that there are other mergers out
there are other companies in playing
again i point to a signa or an anthem
and they're pairing did that have
anything to do with you wanting to make
sure that you and Bruce get together in
a room and iron this deal out no I think
you know it's very interesting we've
been looking at this kind of combination
for five years as a company I know Bruce
and his team have been thinking through
over the last few years about how they
see the future and what we knew with all
the noise going around was that we had
to lock and load on what we thought was
best for our customers best for our
shareholders and best for the people
that we serve in the employer community
and the
vidor community and this was the deal
and so we said you know let all the
noise rage let all the rumors amuse
people in the marketplace and keep the
news cycle going we're going to get this
deal done and move out